Hi everyone, in this video, we're going to take a look at a subsurface profile compared
to a subsurface, as well as we're going to take a deep look at our parallax control,
and how that compares to a bump offset.
So let's get started.
One thing I wanted to point out when it comes to adding subsurface, or even using
multiple type of subsurface materials.
So you can use a simple, simple one.
And I should say nodes that complement the subsurface material, such as the Fresnel index,
you'll notice there's also a complex or more complex Fresnel index, which allow you to
have a bit more control.
Now these are some of the outputs for it, I don't go over it in this class, because
I rarely find use cases for this.
But I wanted to point it out because it is a good call out to be able to actually
see the power of some of these material functions that we've created for you.
You can control the contrast, you can use cheap contrast, you can control the power
of it, invert the Fresnel index, this is kind of a nice little add, and camera vector
as well as normal vector.
So you have those options in there when working with a subsurface control.
You'll notice there's multiple ways to be able to get the look that you want, like
I showed you demonstrate it.
But there are different aspects of it that you may not need.
Now if you work, and what I mean by that is say you want to use a subsurface look and
feel but you need a human.
Now if you're using or creating a stylized piece, you might be able to get away with
just using a subsurface option within your material.
But you may want to get deeper into things and make it so that you're using a subsurface
profile.
And that data can be very helpful.
You'll see it in our metahumans.
So let's actually jump into Unreal and break that down a little bit.
And then we're going to look at the parallax control as a material option.
So inside of Unreal, you'll see here I have a metahuman head.
This was made a customized metahuman.
And I applied the metahuman material in here.
This is using a subsurface profile on the end is using a standard subsurface.
So this is what you can see what I mean by you may be happy with a simple subsurface
because it kind of pushes values a little bit harder, faster, and you can get to where
you need to go a little bit quicker and you can make things a little bit more extreme.
So it might work on a more stylized look and feel.
But over here, this is a more realistic subsurface you can use.
Let's go and take a look at this metahuman synthesized material.
And I'm going to pull over the material into our viewer here.
You'll see it gets pretty deep.
There's all the artists, the lights.
There's the bake groom, we don't have a groom on him.
There's the base color.
And there's the bit normal.
And there's all these different ones in here that you can use and be given you the
ability to be able to control all the different aspects of the skin.
Now again, this is a pretty big deep dive, we don't go into it here, but you're more
than welcome to take a look at this up close.
And you can kind of see the control that you have to be able to push things in the
direction that you need.
You'll see there's a clay material here and chest.
All these things allow us to make us or allow us to be able to have a stronger
look and feels for our characters.
Now, did I just say feels I did.
So if we go in here, you can see there's a deep dive in all of these
parts, even of normal control if we needed to and LODs.
Now, again, we're not going to be dealing with those in detail, but I
wanted to let you know, as you look as you have the skin scattering, you can
also increase these elements, as well as go in here and control your specular,
if you needed to.
And there's a specular map slot for it, if you needed that in there.
And the cavity map power, if you needed that, you can see the cavity
map can affect an overall kind of look and feel for this, almost the
spec or if you want to make the guy a little more shvety, you can do so.
And look, yes, he's already sweating because we're talking about him.
So that allows you to get a little bit more control and a little bit more
realism for sure.
But again, if you're just doing stylized, you can probably be happy with just
using a subsurface and just making it so you have multiple options for
control, like what I showed you with the Jade material.
Now let's go and change our focus for a bit here and take a look at the
parallax occlusion here.
This parallax occlusion is pretty great.
It gives us the optical illusion of three dimensional objects, but they're not here.
Now the only downside about this is the parallax occlusion is a pretty hefty, or
I should say expensive material.
If we go down to our optimization view modes and we go to shader complexity.
Now this guy didn't always show up when we hit alt eight, but it does now.
So if we click on it, you'll actually see a load.
And when it loads, you'll see that he is of the darker nature
here than the light green.
Now, keep in mind, he's not as expensive as he used to be.
But he still is an expensive material.
So if you do use them in quite, maybe you have quite a bit or a lot of
materials that use it, just be mindful of it that you can use it.
Notice it's hitting here, which is still okay.
He's slightly more expensive than the ideal light green.
But when it starts to get red and pink, those were things start to get a little
bit more complicated.
Also, some people don't know this, but you're like, well, I'm going to check
out my material and look at it in preview mode.
The preview mode may not always highlight the complicated detail you might have.
And sometimes it's better to just look at it here to be able to look at the
complexity here to get the full breakdown.
We've improved that greatly, but just be aware.
I just for good checking my P's and Q's.
I like to check the optimization view mode and their shader
complexity in this particular viewport.
So the nice thing about working with this, and I'll show you the setup in
just a second, is as I move my camera around, this looks like this object has
three-dimensional parts to it, and it does not.
This is literally just using an optical illusion to make you think these are
three-dimensional.
Now, the only problem you can run into is you can get blurry areas on the
edges and extreme angles.
Let's actually crack open this.
We'll pick on this particular material.
This is part of our sample pack where you can see this up close.
I'm going to double click, and let's bring this one over.
We're going to look at the parent two.
Let's open this up, and you'll see the global parameters.
Yes, they are grouped.
I did not.
This is part of our pack, so I didn't set that up.
So you'll see there's the base color, the height and the normal, the shadows,
and they use PDO, and you're like, well, what do these even mean, Sean?
Well, let's go into the parent material, take a look.
I'm going to go and crack this open.
This will make things a little bit clearer what's going on under the hood.
Ah, parallax occlusion mapping.
You can see there's a lot of options here.
So we have a height map control, a height ratio here, and minimum steps
and max steps.
Now these steps are going to help with the value of how these angles are going
to be handled so you can adjust these as you need.
These are suggested for this particular look and feel for this piece.
So if you can see, if I switch this to a flat plane, you can really see the
effect on how this can fake the eye.
These are great for like sci fi interiors and you need it to make people think
there's more than actually is, but you will see some blurry areas.
So just be aware of that, especially if your camera's moving rapidly.
You will see that.
So it does fall apart a little bit.
So just be aware of that.
You'll see the texture is pretty simplistic.
You see that the white is the higher
points of interest, the gray middle ground and the black, the indented.
And that's what you got to think about
when you are making this height texture for it.
You got to think in those terms.
You'll see there's a static boolean false.
This specify manual texture size.
This one gets a little bit into the weeds.
I want to get into this too much.
But you have the option to control size as well as shadow occlusion.
You can turn things off and on if you run into problems, display problems.
So we give you that.
You notice there's a light vector MPC.
Speaking of the divot, we talked about the MPCs earlier.
So you can control that light vector if you needed to.
A big quick scaler into a mask that goes into the light vector.
So if you're animating that or you
just need to adjust it with a blueprint, you can do so.
And then you'll see there's a normal map that mirrors kind of what we have
in general for our texture, and then you'll see a little bit of extras
in here in a world alignment.
Now, you're probably wondering why the world alignment.
Well, you'll see the one that I have, the other one.
Just for a second.
This one here, I'll double click on it.
And this guy is without a instance material.
You'll notice he does not have a world
alignment and he's doing OK, but you can use that world
alignment just to adjust some visuals.
And what I mean by that, let's actually
move this camera or I should move the light around here.
It's all dark.
This is what I mean by the preview, not quite showing you actually everything.
It looks like the dark side of the moon.
Anyway, you move the camera around.
Dagnabbit. Why?
So let's go into the view.
So if we go into our view here and let's actually create a light so we can
see this better, so we pull up a light point like there we go.
Let's pull that out and move it up and move it in and increase the strength.
So this light area,
this light will show us a bit of that surface and will even try to imitate
what we have by hitting that texture the way that we want.
Now, you'll notice it is getting let's set it says light to be built.
There you go. Let's do movable there.
And let's also switch to Lumen.
The changes aren't going to be huge when you do use Lumen with this.
And what I mean by that, it's still going to try to render visually,
give you that optical illusion in here.
It'll still try to adhere.
See, we're already Lumen.
I already did change it, so we didn't need to worry about that so much.
You do want to again make sure you're
using hardware texturing and use hardware support with that.
So we're good. We're good.
It just thought probably because I had some previous settings for baking.
But again, as I move this light
around, you'll notice we're getting some highlights.
We also have some other lights in here, too,
that we need and want for our visuals.
And we can change these in our scene.
And you'll see the parallax is taking that information, which is pretty great.
You will notice, though,
when I move the light around that we're not getting actual geometry shadows.
So that's where it can break down.
So just keep that in mind.
Don't just we're not getting a shadow here and here.
And that's what I was trying to demonstrate here.
But he's just not thinking.
He's not deep enough and his colors off, so it wouldn't quite show.
But that's the thing you have to keep in mind.
So if you're using this to really fool
the eye, it literally is just giving a mirage type of effect.
So it isn't actually geometry.
That's it doesn't try to imitate the
shadow as probably as accurately as some people would want.
So if we compare the effect with let's move this over here.
If we compare the effect to a bump offset, which is the old school way,
it actually works pretty good.
Now you'll see the bump offset does catch the light.
Looks pretty great. That isn't too shabby.
But if we compare that over here
to a parallax, parallax looks pretty good.
And the fact that we are getting a more three dimensional look and feel to
everything, it's not too bad, but you'll notice it does blur on the edges where
the bump offset does not blur on the edges as much.
So that is the plus and minus for each.
But we do get a better kind of lighting set up with these.
When you mess with it's going to move this back down.
Let's move this over.
And you'll see the
stones catching light a bit better than some of the other pieces.
There you go. He's a cranked up light anyway.
So to be fair and you'll see that these rocks are moving around
the stones and actually catches light pretty well, especially on the side,
specifically the sides, it does a pretty good job of that.
You notice it just popped along with the shadow.
And that's because we're going past our attenuation.
But again, it's really up to you how
you want to do it, because the bottom is not too bad, it's not too shabby.
But this gives you a bit more three dimensional look and feel to your stuff.
But there can be a blur factor.
So that's why some of those other
options were available.
Let's click on this and go into the material to be able to control that.
And if we go open this up again,
you'll see that we have these steps to control things.
Number of raised shaders casting and be able to create the effect.
And there's also keeping the max low gives us visual distortion and default is 30.
So if you wanted to,
you can crank this up to like maybe 50 if you want it.
And we hit apply and we'll move in and it gets a little bit crisper,
but it does cost more GPU wise, give them mine.
We are still getting blurry on the edge there.
And then we can go back to the 16 if you wanted to.
Let's go back from we did 50, right?
Let's do
60 again,
16, I think it was what I had before.
And then we hit apply.
And then you can see the difference between them.
It's a little bit slight there.
You see it more on the sides.
But that's it with this one.
Hopefully you guys found this enlightening and a good way to approach your materials.
These are two or several complex materials to look at.
This guy is a lot less complex than earlier versions of unreal.
Where he was red and pink.
And you'll notice he's just a darker green, which is fantastic.
That means you might be able to use them a little bit more liberally,
if I can talk, but that's it with this course.
We'll do a quick course wrap up, but I hope you enjoyed it.
And thanks again.